I've ran a insurance company now for you
know 13 years going on 14 years and I've
been in the insurance industry for 20
years I start off with Morgan Stanley
Morgan Stanley gave me a salary plus
commission I made the least money with
Morgan Stanley Deanwood because they
gave me a salary so my commission was
like this then I went to trans transgave
me a commission like this with zero
salary says trans gave me this yeah
he's like Kobe you know he would be ice
cold like did he just say that yeah
this trans things you have to have a
degree to understand the last joke you
just gave but if there's levels to this
this guy's a little too brilliant for I
don't think you need a degree to
understand what assuming room
temperature means yeah go ahead so here
go back going back to the question so it
Transamerica to be exact don't do it
again oh you like that buddy
this is it is what you want me to do
right
so they pay commission then we go we
start our own company and same thing
okay it's commission based here's how it
works go do your thing the upside is Big
you can make tens of millions but at the
same time you got to do the work you got
to go out there you got to do this you
got to do that right this attracts a
certain set of talents where your skill
set as an operator has to be being a
king maker okay where a person like a
daily wire or a fox their model isn't
necessarily to be a king maker they
attract Kings meaning daily wire didn't
Bill Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson is
a king they recruited a king that went
and joined daily wire right Fox News
didn't build back didn't build you
didn't build Tucker didn't build
O'Reilly didn't build a lot of these
guys now some may say well they
certainly didn't build me yeah I was I
would say I was great people at five but
I was constantly like you can't say that
I'm like what could you put on a jacket
I'm like wow
but that but that's the point though so
is your plan to kind of whoever comes
and joins you and runs with you guys
that you're gonna share with them the
tricks to the game that worked for you
so it's almost like and I don't know if
you follow basketball or sports or not
where the Golden State Warriors were
like yeah we're not going to go put a
super team together bring this guy bring
that guy let's draft let's bring in
Steph Curry let's bring in clay let's
bring in Draymond let's build these guys
up and boom let's win four championships
yeah it's your plan to recruit more
Greenies no are you guys also willing to
pay the 5 10 million dollars to recruit
some big names well I would say actually
like for example with daily Wire yeah or
even like the blaze yeah um Jordan
Peterson's an exception he really is an
exceptional it's very recent that they
brought in someone like him because yeah
he is a king he's an unbelievably
talented uh and has an unbelievable
audience I mean if you go back to Fox
News right you're going back a while
like Sean Hannity after 9 11. I think he
was out of Atlanta then he became
nationally syndicated they brought him
and Bill O'Reilly was Inside Edition
back before that had a huge radio show
and he was on I think it was HLN so what
they would do is bring in people who
were kind of that middle tier and then
they were more of a platform to kind of
be a springboard but what you see with a
lot of them is when they leave Fox uh
their podcasts don't really work that
well right because this isn't just sort
of a passive viewership yeah I mean
there's some some folks yeah that's hard
listen well because you don't have
people telling you hey this is who you
want to watch people are tuning into you
because you're interested yeah not
because you have you know a giant crane
Cam and a crotch camera with a
see-through desk did you shave your legs
Stephen did you do this fix your hair do
the makeup I just found the way God made
one of the things that the audience is
watching this I was very impressed to
see he came with a makeup girl that did
his makeup for 45 minutes before yeah it
was very impressive yeah you know the
hair somebody was fixing your hair in
the background you thought the syringes
were for blacks
laughs
so so going back to that I had a couple
guys here I'm I'm talking to uh uh uh
anyway some of the guys from Fox News
and they said to me let me tell you this
is Murdoch but let me tell you the magic
behind Roger rails I said what's that he
was a king maker okay I said tell me
more he says he knew how to get somebody
to poke him here push him here challenge
him here show him this take this angle
think about doing this think about
showing the place he was a king maker so
you know how to do that yeah is your
game plan to go from being a talent to
want to be a king maker that's a long
term here's here's the thing long term
right you know what I'm asking yeah long
term there's no bench like so I said
this a long time ago where I I would
love to retire and I don't mean
necessarily be uh like Les P Diddy like
more Suge Knight like dangling Vanilla
Ice outside of a balcony you know where
if I want to move uh
death row I saw a guy today walking with
a Death Row Records like shirt yeah I
want to say hey death row but then I
don't really know the city that well he
could be like shut up you know he had no
idea
um so uh yeah so I would like I would
love to retire and eventually produce
content more but there's there really
can be no next show like mine you know
later with Crowder unless there's an
environment where it can exist and if
you have to be in an environment where
you have to play ball with these you
know these big Tech effectively I mean
you could say do it trip opoly really
you're really talking about three
companies it can't happen it can't
happen there cannot be a show I mean
Gerald and I talk about this all the
time I can't imagine what our show would
look like if we had to be uh Advertiser
friendly let alone never be suspended on
YouTube like we just decided to forego
the money and by the way I don't really
care so much about the revenue on
YouTube we've talked about this but once
we were demonetizing that was a Vox
apocalypse
um they stopped counting our subscribers
so the number would be about 12 to 15
million subscribers in the main Channel
and what we had was for years I was
monetized uh the channel we were gaining
between 120 to 250 000 subscribers every
single month I think our lowest month in
that period was 80 and our highest might
have been close to like 300. then we
worked in a month in a month yeah every
and every month was over 100 something
thousand the average was 130 something
like that like that yeah then we were
demonetized yeah the Vox apocalypse
because they couldn't remove us because
we didn't violate any policies yeah
right you see Susan wojcicki who was
talking at the recode conference saying
like sorry it's not really hate speech
but we'll create a new rule of
borderline content so the second word
you monetized boom we were down to 10
000 at most thirty thousand subscribers
a month because you can't find us in
browse if you search my name and the
title of the video you'll find something
else someone screwed up at Google
YouTube and accidentally remonetized
this was it for like four months three
or four months we're like What boom 130
to 200 000 average per month again
demonetized down to 10 or 30. and here's
the reason why is because it's right
it's a finances game of course YouTube
wants to migrate people toward
Advertiser content and then of course
they want you to play ball and say by
the way you need to be Advertiser
friendly don't talk about the trans
thing don't talk about the election
don't talk about the vaccines and then
when you have conservatives saying hey
you know what we want to make sure we
keep making this revenue from YouTube
think about that when people say and I
used to be a Libertarian you know until
I I grew out of it and I would still be
considered more libertarian than most
conservatives but it's not a free it's
it's not about a private company doing
what they want when these people enjoy
benefits uh both both as far as policy
as far as taxes from the government
section 230 right when they're protected
they use the law when it's convenient
and then they violate the law when it's
not convenient and they use that to
engineer the kind of content not only
that you see but that is on there so
yeah we kind of said okay we'll we'll
decide like rather than 12 15 million
but not being able to discuss anything
we'll have to build it the hard way it
is a very very difficult slog that's
what bothered me was the lack of access
to new people right if you have a
storefront that's always boarded up it's
really hard to generate new customers
it's the same thing it's hard to
generate new viewers the viewership that
we have
on the show is almost 100 from people
who bookmark it and check it every day
wow so the suggestions for you is not
that high I think it was less than two
percent let
suggestions is less than two percent
browse search suggested they were in
single digits all of them yeah holy sh
they probably suggest people watch
something else other than our show you
you know you know what you know what is
well yeah exactly that's gonna be the
thumbnail with that yeah I mean come on
who's not watching
but but by the way so so going back to
that I bet if if you were to show the
data on what happened with dates
that would be an interesting thing to
look you could probably hey could
someone watched it we could probably
send them to you right now oh if you
have your guy reach out we could send
you at least the before and after I
would love to see that data to just show
it if you can I don't know who in your
communication with if you want to send
them a I think he had an email earlier
setting up some of the tech stuff those
guys might Gerald do you have your phone
with you yeah I do they can text it to
me too if I if I okay if you want to
text it to me I can get it up on the
screen so let me let me go to the next
question which is all within the same
topic
um
so there's a difference when I went from
being an employee to salesperson it
sucked because it had a warm salary now
I don't oh my God it was so annoying
okay yeah then you go from salesperson
you'll learn how to close then you
become a sales leader
you're teaching other people how to
learn how to sell let me tell you it's
very annoying yeah very annoying you
have to have to pay so how do you not
understand use this script if I can do
this they couldn't do it all right so
you got to be patient because it takes a
long time so then I went from being a
sales leader to seal I sucked as a seal
so I go in I'm like I have to find out
what it is being a business owner is
different than a CEO right so for you do
you really as a as a talent like I I
used to sit there and watch a lot of the
guys I was in business with who were
very very good these people I respected
up till today I respect for what they
built why did they never go start their
own companies and I would ask them
you're very good why didn't you go start
your own company deal with compliance
deal with all that stuff why don't you
just why don't you stay put he says I
don't want that life yeah so Talent
think about O'Reilly think about Hannity
think about Tucker think about you know
I can give you a bunch of these names
think about on the other side Cuomo
tamper madal Cooper think about all of
these guys why did they never go and say
I want to start my own company okay and
then let's go on the podcast side
because you may say what's a different
reading the teleprompter you know and
today and you see their eyes going like
this the entire time okay he's reading
the teleprompter okay a lot of people
this is hard what you do is very hard to
keep people's attention a hundred
thousand people's attention you did one
for 16 hours I don't know what 16 hours
yeah 16 hour life that's ridiculous yeah
so do you really as a
creative want to go into dealing with
talent and telling them and giving them
tips on how to build and manage uh
I'm not going to tell them and here's
the thing that's different yeah it is
different uh well that's also why he's
CEO yeah no it's been a company I've
been running a company for a very long
time you have 20-something employees
that's why I've owned Lottery
like like uh Ben Shapiro and Jeremy
where Ben is the talent and Jeremy's
more like the day-to-day CEO I don't
know what their inner workings are well
based on what I've heard I don't either
by the way just so you know a lot of
people because they had money guys you
know we don't have that that's the
difference we don't have like we that's
one thing too we've never taken a dime
of seed money we've always made it back
literally within the first quarter
explain why that's important the fact
that what is the difference if they do
because some people may say well you
know I know you're saying since Stephen
but the fact that Ben and Jeremy and
those guys have money from those oil
guys that I think is like the or
fracking guys that got the three and a
half billion dollars and they're fun and
getting here is 50 million 100 million
300 million whatever they're doing so
they can go get the bigger guys right
what's wrong with that what is so no
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with it well I should say this we do
have technically seed money it's you
it's my club right we're not funded by a
foreign caliphate like The Young Turks
you know in some way and I'm partially
joking yeah uh we don't have you know
oil bearing money we have uh people
that's it we don't have a lot of
sponsors either and by the way 100 of
the sponsors wanted to come because we
always make sure that they get more
value than they pay for you know in this
you know this in this industry right
there's a lot of paying for views and
downloads that don't really happen yep
so for us we go to them in the way we've
con uh structured contracts is okay if
you don't you know if you if you don't
like what we do because we don't do
libraries we do these really weird
commercials sometimes that get a little
get a little off the off the beam so if
you don't like it just don't just don't
pay for it and then like we we don't
need to do this we think you're gonna
like it 100 of the time they do but you
have to coach those people creatively
right it used to be for example Gerald
remembers this I was I would be yelling
on the phone with billionaires I'm like
no you don't know what you're talking
about where I had people come in when I
had I think half a million subscribers
they said you know free is the enemy of
Premium because at that point we had
built a lot of subscribers I said well
you don't understand it's free it's an
advertising venue it reaches people and
rather than tricking people into paying
you provide value added and people will
pay because they want to support you
right sometimes people go hold on a
second I'm paying and um basically the
show is out there for free and all these
sponsors are on here whether it's four
five ten you know and they go usually it
used to be at one point in time we would
pay so it would be ad-free they go what
am I paying for we've always tried to
make it really really clear and provide
value added now as far as um with
content with Talent
um I'm not going to tell them what to do
at all like they they can do what they
want because these are people who I
believe provide value added yeah and if
it doesn't work then they can go on
their merry way and take their
subscribers with them like there's
there's no exclusive completely unique
in this industry like there's nobody out
there in the conservative space that is
doing something like that and
essentially we just kind of got thrown
into this a little bit looking at all
the contracts going gosh is everybody
really doing stuff like this that just
really doesn't value the creator doesn't
value the audience the way that we think
you should and then saying we can
probably do something better and really
the better is just giving people the
opportunity to be creators the
opportunity he was never given in some
of those previous roles like hey we want
you to fit this mold for us we want you
to do it this way telling creators like
look you've already started to kind of
have some success that's great that's
fantastic why don't you come and add
more value to our viewers and bring your
viewers with you add more value to them
as well yeah right so that it's just a
different model where we don't have to
and go back to your question on the
money
if it's your money versus somebody
else's money that's different right you
put a different work ethic behind every
dollar that you have that is on the line
somebody else's it doesn't mean you
don't value it but also there's
different interest in it they're going
to be able to dictate a little bit more
what happens if you have other people's
money yeah I have investors in my other
business I have a wine business and of
course those guys want to see a return
and if things aren't going the way that
they should go and maybe I've made all
the calls they're going to say hey you
need to make different calls or we need
a different you in that role plus
they're usually drunk well that's why I
chose my business
it's hard to be mad in the mind
everyone's very happy no but that's also
why Gerald you know when we were looking
at this I was because For the Longest
Time right I'd get to this point well
you know with like contracts we have a
certain period you're allowed to
renegotiate often contracts are framed
but that's a very short period of time
yeah and then it'd be under the gun
where I still have always owned
everything but like this isn't really
something that I want to do or I don't
want to do it this way where Gerald said
hey look what if you were to do this and
suggested something similar to what
we're doing and I turned to him and I
said Gerald you know I can't do that and
he said unless I go full time because he
knows that I can't manage the sales and
also do a show every day which you know
for every hour people see it's four
hours of prep just for me I mean we have
to be right on the research we make all
of our research publicly available every
single reference it's like a
bibliography uh and we post it every
single day yeah and then we also you
know we have to do these sketches we
have to we only have punch we have
photoshops we have guests we it's very
it's more of a television show than a
radio show online it's really kind of
the only one
um in that vein and that takes a lot of
work and one thing I will say is you
said that you weren't
a good did you say not a good CEO not a
good sales trainer I was not in 2014.
okay 2013. I was not a good CEO yet so
here's the thing I'm the one thing I
will say the only thing that I'm really
decent with in business is you know the
old Wayne Gretzky quote eq's Mission
basketball the Canadian meme like let's
go to hockey no one knows
um
no no not that one wasted don't go where
the is go where the Puck's going to
be yeah I've always been pretty good at
understanding where the puck is going to
be beyond that I have always had a
problem to struggle with uh managing
people who aren't like me and you're
probably this way right as a
self-starter sometimes like the people
have just we've worked with for forever
like the retention rate is insane with
some of these people are people who you
go hey I need to get this done they go
great and they find a way to do it I'm
results oriented there are some people
who need to be managed more and then
they'll get upset if they feel like
they're being micromanaged the people
who I've worked with really well are
people who are selfish I don't
necessarily know how to manage people
who aren't similar to me I'm a creative
type Cheryl's good at that and that's
where we're at the point now he's been
working part-time he's been on the show
we were just talking about how because
he has a great radio voice he used to
come on and talk about Theology and uh
Christian apologetics and then he would
be in that second share uh and and he's
always run a business and we've always
wanted to make sure that we could
maintain a friendship but then it got to
a point where it's undeniable or he
would see me kind of getting just buried
like I just don't know there's no way
yeah there's no way to do it I think you
kind of alluded to it we a lot of people
think oh guys you guys have been off for
what 10 weeks or something like that
right we've been shooting
shooting like crazy writing like all
these different ideas like all of that
takes an incredible amount of time and
to run a business on top of that and to
kind of handle I mean the fires that you
have to put out in this industry
especially when you have a Target on
your back like he does it's it's just it
drains you and so we had to build some
infrastructure up with personnel and
just making sure we had people in the
right places made some new hires got the
team expanded because creators not only
want a good contract right they want to
keep their subscribers they want to know
who they are like God forbid you have to
you get to know who the people that are
paying you money are when you work for
some of these people they wanted to have
the ability to not have to deal with all
the back-end like editing and all the
other promotional stuff and people
saying can you just help me with
monetization like I know how to create
good content but I don't know all of
these different things it's kind of like
dentists you can go get a loan from A
bank right now being a dentist fresh out
of dental school they'll give you money
left and right and then everybody the
financial services people are right
behind the dentist when they're going
because they know they know their craft
they don't know how to run a business
right and make money that's what a lot
of these creators are doing but you know
you're right but they just don't know
how to run them by the way dentists
don't you know a lot of well now there
are no Twitter I knew a girl she had
just graduated yeah she had just got now
she was like you're never going to get a
loan and she goes oh yeah the bank was
ready to give me like 150 what I'm
trying to start my business and I'm like
I've got to model this proven over seven
years most doctors have no clue what to
do money they're clueless with money you
go to the house they're making 600 Grand
you think they have everything on no
nothing nothing and the reason is
because everybody thinks they know it
all because their name is what doc so
the challenge is you're a great content
creator but it's different managing
managing Talent so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]